i have a master's in chemistry i have a
master's in business administration
i have a master's in management
here one two three four five
so these are five from colleges i never
went to
okay and they were issued in less than
three days
[Music]
let me surprise you a little bit more
you can even get a phd
you can even be called a doctor you can
get all this stuff
like doctors yeah yeah seriously
you can actually become a doctor you can
be called a doctor
and the best part let me let me baffle
you absolutely
you can see all these these are stamps
from the government
you can get it stamped from the
government even
a toilet paper an ordinary piece of
paper
okay just just have a look at this just
have a look at this can you see
how shabby it is yeah okay
this was attested by the government
and explain to people what attested by
the government means that means they
stamp their seal of approval and say yes
this is what
it seems like this is an authentic
original
document valid they have verified it
the college is real the degree is real
the paper is real
you have like five degrees a master's in
chemistry an mba
you've got all these things and you're
gonna break down
how you got to them this is really
really old
in the sense that i knew fake degrees
existed
right from a very young age how my
mother had it
my father had it uh literally anyone
could get it
anyone they had fake degrees no they got
fake degrees
to make sure that they would get uh the
promotion in their company
just just to make you understand the
middle east is actually
a very racist place to be they don't
advertise this in the
papers they don't talk about it in the
media they always show a very positive
image
why because in every newspaper you have
someone from the government
who literally checks each and every
publication each and every article and
says no this no
change this so they make it sound as if
it's paradise
but here's the limitation that they have
they are under the impression that
people from the west
are highly educated they are very
sophisticated they
are the superior race okay
while people from the east are dumb the
reason being is currency
the the dollar is much more valuable so
what happens is
they used to get these guys to come down
there um now i do not know if
uh western expats had fake degrees okay
i'm not sure of that but i can tell you
for a fact
that the asians uh initially they didn't
have these fake degrees but once they
started to get into the market that you
could get a degree
for those days it was as less as
150 i'm talking of 20 years ago
why would anyone get a real degree if
you get it for that shape
and i'll tell you why did they want
their degree the only reason that they
wanted a degree is
if you wanted to climb up the corporate
ladder you have to show that you're an
mba
so once you give them the sheet of paper
okay that i'm a master's degree holder
they will take this give it to the hr oh
okay he has a master's degree thank you
very much that's it
you you're considered an educated person
working in the company
and then you qualify by default to apply
for a promotion
what do you expect the easiest way is
get yourself this
how did you get yourself that that's
where we need to go to
okay um the story is simple make the
long story short after i
resigned from my job i thought i would
start my own business it didn't work out
i thought i'd be a trainer a speaker
it was not working out for me so
eventually i realized i needed a degree
i needed a degree in order to even apply
for a company because if you apply for a
multinational company they'll ask you
give us your qualifications so when i
was checking in the papers
i found the ad which i sent to you it
said
fast track mba no
degree required you can just get an mba
just imagine you can get a fast act
those days golf news college times they
used to advertise this today they don't
okay so i was like okay you can get a
fast track nba without even a degree wow
that's
is it right yeah and uh so what i did i
called this guy
this uh chap i called him and i said i
would like to get an
mba but i don't have a you know
college degree he said oh this is a
special program from the indian
government he gave me a big
litany of stuff and i knew that he was
bullshitting i kind of had the gut
feeling
but the thing that surprised me was i
felt he was a very young chap
okay so i told him um okay
can i come down uh i have the money so
the minute i told him i have the cash he
said
why don't you come down she was very
happy now i didn't have the money
okay so when i went down there because
when you can see a person face to face
you can judge the guy
i knew the guy was young so i said i
have a
exceptional deal for you she was like
what is it
i give him the proposition that i would
train the people in this company because
i was a professional trainer i did
[ __ ] with him that
you know certification all that and
revenue generation so he was very happy
i said i'll give it to you for free
because what i wanted was
to meet the owner of this company he
said he'll speak to the owner owner said
yes after a few days
and then they actually booked a hotel
room uh
where i had to conduct the seminar i
conducted the seminar it was great
everything was fine
and the owner that was when i met him
for the first time
and he took a liking on me especially
given the fact that i come from the
southern part of india i had only the
mike tyson tattoo
only this much this all came later on
okay okay
yeah so he he kind of liked it and i
told him listen i want to get an mba he
said no
no problem i'll get you the mba for free
so i was like whoa
that's great you know you're saying i'll
which degree you want i'll give you for
free
okay so now this guy tells me he's going
to give me a degree so
so for me what the hell do i care for me
the only thing that matters
is i can show this piece of paper and i
can get jobs
to feed myself to take care of my life
yeah i i didn't care how was i gonna get
it so
i was thinking more in these lines and
then he just
gave me like you know the godfather he
gave me an offer i couldn't refuse
this is the infamous
letter offer letter the offer letter
so he offered you a job he goes hey we
like you so much we're gonna offer you a
job and get you a degree
he he literally offered what would it
take
for you to join me name your price
okay and what are we talking about here
when is this when is this give us a day
this was
the date was 20th february 2011.
okay he put it across that he wanted to
legitimize this training
do you know do you know what you're
really doing you just think you're
training training what
just training sales that's what i
thought i
i was under the impression that i'm
going to train people
okay and give them value and we're going
to grow the brand
what he had in mind was the money that
was coming from the illegal business
he was going to take this the business
of a fake degree
yeah okay so
you know for me it didn't matter what
the hell he was doing what mattered is
okay i'm doing my job properly until
then okay then i joined him
everything was fine happy happy
everyone's going good until
i i found out what was actually
happening
now with every email with every document
he was taking my signature
okay and that is where i
didn't even at that time it didn't
strike me that i was signing all the
documents
he's running the show i'm signing the
documents okay just keep it
clear what's going on is anytime he's
doing anything he needs somebody to sign
and he just puts lloyd macedo yeah so i
was i was signing the baby
in fact it was not only me it was two
three other people okay so he was taking
our signatures now
i didn't i still didn't think about this
i still didn't it didn't strike me that
what was i doing where it actually
baffled me was when he took me to india
and he made me meet these people with
this cash
which we spoke about the money that i
was like
man this is really big this is not small
this like operation is really really big
it's like
you know you're taking like letterheads
and 2 000 people and 3 000 people so i
was like
for me it was you know everything was
like brand new it was like a shock
and then when he sat down with this guy
at indira gandhi university and mahatma
gandhi university
he actually decided sign up a deal where
they would open up centers in
uae bahrain qatar oman saudi five
countries
and i was like you're gonna open i
thought he was opening training centers
he's going to open all these fake degree
certificates in all these countries
okay and i was like listen you know if
you're going to open up stuff you need
to have systems in place you can't just
start opening up
but he wanted to be the next jeff bezos
the mark zuckerberg the elon musk he
wanted to be that big you know
of like fake degrees or what or is that
what you wanted
to legitimize you just wanted to be rich
okay well fake degree seems like a good
way to do it
okay so he was super ambitious he
believed nothing could touch him
okay so as he started telling me all
this i
we started to disagree on a lot of
things
this india trip that we went from being
really close friends we started to argue
and debate and
we were having massive indifference okay
between us
we were not agreeing on and that is
where things started get really bad
at this point you probably know how the
fake degree process
works no because you now have a fake
degree from him how does that how does
that work
i mean he says he's going to get you a
fake degree does it just come in the
mail like what
where does it appear okay he doesn't
just put your name on top of something
does he
okay uh to make you understand how he
had taken me for one of these centers
okay one of these centers how they do it
what they do is they get all these
people come to the office
um at a stated time it is going to be
locked from the outside
okay people come in and it's locked out
so outside it shows closed
inside all the people are there lights
everything else
so it looks like a training institute
everybody will be seated on a particular
desk you will have the question papers
i've sent you the template you'll have
the question papers there
you'll have blank sheets of paper you're
supposed to write down
the answers the answers are also
supplied you write the question you
write the answer
so it's like you've actually hanging on
slow down slow down because that's
amazing so oh wait so they give you the
questions
but they give you the answers yeah and
you have to write the answers down
now if in case and you have to write it
within the three hour time now this is
where the upsell happens like
you know a mcdonald's burger would you
like an upsize so in the same way
many guys because they have not written
a paper for so many years
and i'm telling you this you're talking
of managers in multinational companies
managers are senior guys goodness
gracious okay
so as they are writing their hands will
pay and they would be like you know i
can't and
the guy the owner was busy waiting there
oh if you want we can
give you an upgrade so what is the
upgrade we'll get somebody else to write
the papers where you don't have to write
it
you can just go so you pay a little bit
extra
and somebody else will sit and write
down the paper for you okay
now why do they need these why do they
need these fake answer sheets
if you kind of already have like this
template you can just write something so
if there is any verification done you
have all the papers oh he wrote the
people
oh you can say oh whatever
and it's backdated you wrote it today
but it's backlated like four years five
years ago
how much how much did everything cost
like bachelor's degree master's degree
phd
uh you uh the rates that were in 2011 i
don't know the rates right now
uh i'm not been in touch with him ever
since ever since he tried to
get me killed okay um
it was you can get one for a thousand
dollars you can even get for five
hundred dollars
okay that depends on who you're getting
yeah bachelor's then
it goes from a thousand dollars it goes
to let's say two thousand or three
thousand dollars for a masters
and it depends where you wanna get you
wanna get it from the united states you
wanna get it from uk
quality you know it depends it's like
are you buying a toyota lexus bmw rolls
royce
and then over there also you have
multiple options
okay would you want it to be signed on
by a minister a big guy
the bigger the name the bigger the name
the bigger the amount
and unless people question it probably
oh of course
there are some people whose names if you
take nobody would dare
question okay so i've got to ask because
it just confuses me maybe i just don't
know how things
so like let's say you get a uk degree
right
but it's so they're wanting in it
wouldn't you need it attested by the uk
government or somewhere in the uk
man the middle east there are people
who get all this thing done because
within the middle east
see i i do not know what i know is what
i can tell you
sure yeah i don't expect you to have
answers forever yeah
see um as far as i've known until
until lately people even migrated to
canada
australia london u.s with these fake
degrees
once they were there after that they got
rid of it after they migrated
okay however at some stage they found
out that people were coming with fake
degrees
that is why the uk that is why canada
now refuses to recognize any medical
degree or any
you can be a master's you can be a phd
but once you come there
if you want to take up you need to write
the exam ah
so that is why many of them after they
go there then they re-enroll themselves
for a college degree there
it's a massive business oh here's one
more thing which people don't think
about
once after people migrate over there
they have their fake degree and they've
gone there and they thought oh i'm going
to live there happily ever after
after they get the survey they get a
call after a few months
from somebody else who says i'm from the
government we found out that you have a
fake degree
and we're going to report it to the
authorities now please don't report
you know my family is here my wife is in
my kitchen oh but i can't do anything
justice should be
served enough please please is there
anything i can do
um you know there's nothing please okay
since since you know you have your
family
i can do something but you know then
again there are people i need to take
care of
so then they once again take money
and how yes guess who gave this
information the whole thing this whole
circle can cost anyone from
what they put in just a thousand dollars
to two thousand dollars can go all the
way to twenty thousand dollars
per person so just multiply if you have
two thousand people a month on an
average if you're talking of
two to five thousand dollars was that
his official run rate i mean that was
the run rate that he was working at was
about 2000 degrees a month
yeah you wanted more this guy was
actually a a toilet cleaner
he was actually a toilet cleaner he was
a guy who was working making sandwiches
and from there he ended up being this
guy who literally had
millions to even buy a university in
india
it's the great american story from
toilet cleaner to
fake degree holder by the way two
thousand
people paying you twenty thousand
dollars each that can't be right is that
right
oh my god uh take it around let's say
they're probably not all paying you
twenty thousand let's say so
take an average take an average of two
thousand dollars two thousand people pay
you two thousand dollars
it's four million dollars a month
wow it's serious money okay
let me surprise you and by by shocking
you the climax of the story so after we
came down we had a
massive fallout and i told him see
listen this whole thing is going to
collapse this whole system is going to
collapse if you're going to have
branches in saudi qatar bahrain but he
was hyper ambitious and i was adamant
and you know i was a hot blooded guy and
our egos clashed until
one day when i was sitting in the
apartment i was pretty pissed off with
him we are not talking
the office people found out so one of
them the senior guy came to me and said
can i ask you something he said yes have
you ever thought about
the fact that you can fall into trouble
he came in the evening to tell me this
i said what do you mean me fall in
trouble he's the one who's doing the
fake degrees
so he said you never thought about it
did you i said no
who's putting all the signatures and
i'll tell you at that time
it's like i froze literally for i said
wait i'm just signing those papers he's
saying do you know what you're signing
i said yeah he's telling me man is it
that's what you think
he's saying he takes your signature
multiple sheets of paper he takes your
email address
he's saying he has access to the server
it's like you sending the email
because he can prove it that you join
the company you're the director you're
the one who's issuing everything
i i'll tell you the whole world just
came like stand still and i was like
oh bloody hell he's saying he can put
you behind bars
if he wants to and he can say he didn't
know what you were doing
and that is where i got panicked and
that was when i actually sent the email
that i sent you if you check the date
i send it to i send it to the federals
like the fbi you have in the movie the
fbi the highest levels in uae
i send it to the police i send it to the
cid i send it to the fbi the
highest the federal uh in dubai you
figure out you're the fall guy
and you're basically the guy who's going
to take the blame for everything
yeah and so then you go okay well let me
get out in front of this basically
yeah i want to do i wanted to come out
clean okay right
so i i took photographs uh which i've
sent it here i took photographs at that
time of his house everything else i
prepared a powerpoint
and i gave it to the police the police
said
this is not our jurisdiction go higher
up so i went to the cid that is criminal
investigation department
in the uae i went to them they said oh
this
is the federal it's national security
fine i i send it to them they set up a
meeting
in i remember this clearly ajman city
center
ajman city center at the coffee shop
near starbucks
i went there whole the evidences
certificates
your heart's got to be beating out of
your chest you're reporting the boss who
got you everything
uh because you suddenly realize you're
kind of the fall guy for this whole
criminal operation where you thought you
were going to do something legit
your heart's beating out of your chest
you've been told to take it all the way
up
are you thinking you're a whistleblower
are you thinking you're covering
well i was just [ __ ] scared and i wanted
to get out of it i just wanted to get
out of it
so um my my head was not thinking
you know because i was i was absolutely
scared man
so i went i i gave it to them
i had the hard disk which was like
around
five terabyte or something two terabyte
of all
templates two terabyte of question
papers and templates
okay i gave it to them they said okay
we'll check
so i sat down there waiting they went
they're checking in starbucks
they said okay we this man will be
assigned to you you can communicate with
him
we'll get back to you so he tells me to
meet him after
you know seven days or so after seven
days i meet them there again
and i'm waiting for them to tell me fine
thank you very much we are going to take
uh the necessary stuff this guy's going
to be jailed waiting for that kind of
news
he comes and tells me that you know we
checked everything
uh why do you want to get into all this
trouble you can just
yeah you know just go just do your thing
enjoy life have fun i said what do you
mean have fun
you know i was like what have fun
is then he told me habibi
if your government if your government
don't care
your minister don't care why you care
and i was like uh
what what what did you you know i i was
just
jumping what did you just say just go
live happy mind your own business
basically
we don't wanna we don't we're not
touching this yeah we
don't care basically we don't give a
[ __ ] that's what he wanted to tell me
and i was like
i'll tell you i just i just felt the
blood drain out i was like
did i just waste my time yeah and then
then i'd approach the media golf news
kalish times all the papers
i went and told them what happened as
soon as i reached home
i got an email the same email that i
forwarded to these police and to these
people
the same email i get back from this guy
saying
what the [ __ ] is this from your boss
your boss finds out
yeah he sent he sent the same powerpoint
he sent everything back to me and says
what the [ __ ] is this question ma
question question and i'll tell you
you know sorry to use this term but i
felt my balls come right in my mouth i
was like
i'm finished no sooner than this
happened
next thing i knew he comes in with 20 30
guys who are working there all the
people who i knew
he comes in he doesn't come he sends his
wife
because he knows she's a muslim lady i'm
not going to touch her okay
and it comes with 20 30 guys and they
tell you know
that's why they started to bully me uh
they're going to cancel your visa
they beat you up they knock you around
no no they
they don't but obviously you wanted to
scare me with the numbers
right but i was you know he just wanted
to because even he is wrong he knows
that he doesn't want
drama okay so he said listen we'll pay
you the money we'll give you everything
cancel a visa you can go your own way so
i was like
okay i have nothing else i can do right
now
i was like okay so the following day
signed the papers
he made sure he got me thrown out of the
apartment
okay i got through some people's help i
got
a temporary place to stay okay and
he made sure that i was taken to the
airport and i was sent off
now this was where you know because i
came from a broken family
nobody wanted to be in touch with me and
by the time
i was at the airport i didn't know he
had done this he sent an email to
every person i knew he hacked into my
system
everyone's email he sent them that i was
into drugs and i was into
illegal stuff i was into prostitution i
was into fake degrees
means he made sure that everyone got
some story about me nobody wanted to
even pick up my phone
because i wanted help now just imagine
for a guy who has been
in the middle east his whole life who
even though has an indian passport
has never been to india who hardly knows
even if india just been for a holiday or
a few days
in the middle east uh you never get a
citizenship you can stay there 30 years
you can say 60 years you can stay
like five generations but you will be
still having the passport
of the country from where your ancestors
came or where you came from
right you're never you're never brought
into the nation you're never a national
yeah you're never a citizen so here i'm
being sent to india with no money
with no friends no relatives nobody
wants to pick up my phone and
uh that was where that video uh 2011
loya massive suicide
on youtube i uploaded that as my final
video before i kill myself
yeah everybody can find this they can
look it up right now yeah
so i went there to kill myself because
i had no money i had nothing to live for
i managed to
have the courage to tell myself okay i
would just take one more day i didn't
think of living
just one more day i would live and you
can see it in that video
finally i decided okay i would give
myself a second chance i would
want to live life once again and that is
where i contacted
my ex-mentor my mentor who is
the ex-head of dubai police he's ex-head
of the bible his ambulance section
he knew me from many many years he knew
me as
honest genuine guy through him
he knew that i was a good guy he he got
my band removed others you cannot get it
removed
okay he got it removed he got me back
once i came back
started to start my life from zero lucky
for me
i managed to get a ted talk that is why
i titled myself extra just to get the
tech talk
so i tried to myself no you did not dude
you go i i need to get a ted talk
how can i get it if i'm more chatting it
was
it was actually my mentor who pushed me
for
because my confidence was completely
gone i didn't believe
i could get anything so i i applied for
it i got it the stone of judgement where
i spoke how we judge others because i
had this tattoo so it was very easy to
judge me
from there things started to work well i
even got a coca-cola
ad and there i started to gain
prominence and there
he was very afraid because i started to
get popular
online okay so this is your mentor
that's afraid
no no this this ex-employer of mine
oh okay got it got it got it i got it
gotta get it okay got it so
there was always that tension that we
would brush paths or
we would bump into each other so
later on gulf news featured an article
about him
okay fake degrees you can just google
search
golf news fake degrees and that is where
the ua authorities because uae is very
particular that it shouldn't ruin its
name
okay when it comes to the image of the
country
they will take action this is very much
like china like we typically americans
kind of
understand that china's like this where
they only print news
that is good for the country but what
you're saying is the middle east is like
that in general
no middle east is it's it's massive man
it's it's
it's huge and just so that you know uh
us
gets a lot of money from the middle east
oh yeah i gotta get that oil money and
natural gas
money yeah they're very good friends
they're very very good friends
okay so now what's happening is
okay they're getting very popular okay
they're
uh sorry i was i was getting popular and
the minute i informed because my brand
was so strong i started
speaking on issues like how you speak on
fake degrees i started speaking on
uh important issues that affected expats
but within the
uh limitations that i had okay because
if you're in the country you can't speak
bad about the country
okay right so i was only speaking of
expat the struggles that they're going
through and so i got in touch with this
journalist from gulf news
he's one of the top most journalists and
i told him about these fake degrees he
printed out a story the fake degrees
of the middle east okay uh
you can check it out on gulf news and
they immediately started
exposing these guys uae doesn't want its
image to be effective
the rule in uae is you do whatever [ __ ]
you want as long as it's
quiet the nigerian scammer why did he
get caught by the american authorities
because he was busy advertising you can
just google search
uh nigerian scammer uae okay because he
was advertising on
instagram he was showing so much wards
of cash he was saying butcher larabee or
showing rolls-royce
even this guy calm mirza commerza is
another guy from the uk pakistani origin
he was showing off if you show off
you get into trouble if the name of the
country is
put down then you get into trouble let
me interject real quick
i've got i've got to say this because i
think for those of you listening this
can sound all like a story
guys i i'm going to pull several things
up on screen right now but
right here i have in front of me gulf
news 143 degrees detect
fake degrees detected last year but this
is pretty funny
abu dhabi says the ministry of higher
education has never accredited or
equalized
any fake degree obtained from foreign
countries which is
kind of hilarious right um but then we
also have another thing that verifies
what you're saying
fake degree holders get fake calls
overseas call centers impersonate uae
government officials to extort money
that's what you're talking about how
they call you say hey
it's massive it's huge but what i'm
saying is that
there's actual news outlets that are
talking about this
alongside you so this is uh verifying
what you're saying in other words
it's it's a big thing that goes on it's
uh it goes on on multiple levels
you you not believe the amount of people
who are
involved in these scams there are
doctors
performing surgeries they are not
qualified to do that
in fact let me blow your brains out by
telling you this
a government hospital that was supposed
to break even after 10 years
broke even within one and a half year
how i knew
my close friend used to work in that
hospital
and do you know how did they break even
nine years
ahead of time during the meeting during
the meeting
the doctors with the director are
sitting down and they asking
these are the questions they're asking
which finger can you amputate
if you amputate uh each finger if you
let the infection spread
we can amputate once more and we can get
some more money
each doctor is given a target and you
are supposed to ensure that you achieve
the target
do you know that so many women of
operations basically do you know this
that if your wife gets pregnant
it costs maybe a thousand five hundred
to two thousand dollars
for a natural birth but if they give you
a caesarean
it automatically jumps to almost like uh
25 000
so how much is that uh 25 000. six
thousand seven thousand dollars
so where is one thousand very seven
thousand dollars guess which one the
doctor would love to do
that is why the majority of uh cases
pregnancy are all cesarean and after the
baby is born
make sure that the baby is sick make
sure that the baby is kept in an
incubator because every day you'll have
to spend 500
to keep the baby in the incubator the
more the sick the baby is
the more the money the hospital makes so
you know that
i think people are going to say i want
to continue with this topic
of you know the problem with getting
fake degrees but i got to say this
people are going to say loy you're just
bitter because you got kicked out of the
country why are you coming forward now
you have the fake degree you've
benefited from it so what incentive why
are you coming forward
are you just some great guy are you just
some wonderful guy
no um on my on my channel i don't want
to advertise but on my channel i keep
things as
transparent as possible okay the reason
i want to bring this
out today the reason i is because i've
been seeing what you're doing
until you tell me before you started to
do this who was actually doing it
how many people lost their life savings
how many people lost that same a lot how
many people
uh you know there are people who want to
kill themselves man
because they actually borrowed money and
they gave these gurus
i interviewed a guy i interviewed a
family who lost their
son i saw that i saw that i mean not
even want to commit
i mean they do people die from this
stuff it's terrible
see i i'm involved today i can speak
about what is happening in the
middle east in fact i'm the only person
and obviously because of my face and
people see this uh
they never forget okay but i'm the only
guy and do you know this that
i've got death threats i have literally
got
calls telling me you better be careful
because your wife and you are going to
fall into trouble
people have threatened my wife people
have threatened me people have
threatened my baby
and they have people have so what i'm
hearing
is you basically feel feel like the
truth needs to get out
and you want to come out see your
uh until now i kept all this with me i
kept all this
because these are memories these are
memories that i've carried with me
and there is no way to get this out it's
only after i saw your channel i was like
there is someone who is telling the
truth there's someone who's listening to
all this
you might as well tell people i'll i'll
tell you where
where i realized that it's harming
people one is the doctors who are
operating
and butchering people that is number one
for business for money
the second one is someone who has worked
very hard throughout his life
and another guy who has faked his way
the student who has worked hard
his dreams are shattered and he has no
other choice
other than to say the only way for me to
succeed is for me to go
this path which is wrong right
after i left uae i realized i'm the only
expatriate who left ue and can
make the problems known of people what
they are facing
i'll tell you this this what you're
talking about all these certificates
okay
this will still continue even today
even if you take all the evidence and
you give it to the government
and they make a big hue and cry about it
yeah that's that's what they're doing
they're saying 143 fake degrees detected
last year
if there's 143 detected how many do you
think are given out
come on man yeah uh these big guys
i give you the name the profile of that
guy he's still issuing fake degrees
he's still doing it see the the problem
is
um you have all these guys who get these
phds who get
right now right now at this very moment
there are doctors who are operating on
people
who are not qualified it's horrifying
you told me also about pilots can you
speak about that that blew my mind
uh pakistani pilots are banned from
european countries because they found
out
pakistani pilots have all faked their
qualification
you don't have to believe a word i say
just google search man do you feel like
the people at the top are bad people
it's a matter of survival
well okay i i agree with that up to a
point when you're
when you're trying to go from zero to
you know living wage i agree okay let me
tell you something
when you go from living wage to millions
and millions of dollars it's no longer a
matter of survival
let me give you a real shocker this
actually happened few days ago
okay this girl this girl
young girl married she has a child she
has a husband husband lost a job
she has to support the child she has a
mother she has a father she was working
in emirates airlines she had to get a
job
the job was available she applied for it
the guy straight away told her how badly
you won this job
she said it's a matter of life and death
okay
prove it to me how badly you want it he
ended up sleeping with her
for the next six to seven days then she
had to do it again
with his boss then she had to do it
again with his boss
and she literally when she was speaking
to me i thought she wanted personal
branding
she just wanted to speak to somebody and
she cried and she was telling me
i felt so violated but there's nothing i
can do because
i don't have a visa i need a visa my
husband has taken a bank loan his
business collapse he will be arrested i
will be arrested we can never go back
home
we will be jailed for life i need a job
to support my family
so tell me what advice can you give
someone like this
what will you tell them take the right
path pray to god
be a good person it's see it's very easy
for us to give advice and say be a good
person
do good but when you have a system like
this
what what do you do man yeah so it's
so what i'm trying to do is people are
doing this for survival
yeah yeah no and i and i and i don't
blame those people
i mean i'm never i i never am after the
victims i'm never after those people
i talk i try to talk about the people at
the top who are
creating these systems right it's never
going to stop
it's never going to stop i'm still happy
that you're speaking out about it i'm
still happy that these get
issues are getting spread somewhere
because ultimately that is how things
end up changing
if you never talk about it if you never
bring light to it that's the
that's really the way that things
continue as
kind of as planned the way you shake
things up is you start bringing
light to big problems people start
paying attention because they
say hey this isn't right and you start
to slowly effect change
uh the worrying part is when you have
countries who do not
allow a free press i mean you know the
united states we definitely have our
problems but one thing that we do get
right
is that you can say what you want and
you can criticize the government you can
criticize anyone you want in the
government
and you're not going to be thrown in
jail you're not going to be there's no
you might you might get cancelled on
twitter right but
you know it's not it's not the same as
disappearing off the face of the planet
uh but you know i'm grateful that you're
speaking up about this stuff i'll say
right now we have we haven't talked very
extensively beyond you know you telling
me about this
whole scam but i will say i appreciate
what you're doing with this
and um i really want to thank you for
shining a light on this it's i think
it's really meaningful stuff
now the only reason i came is because i
respect what you do i
bumped into your videos this is not me
praising you or anything
um ever since by the way ever since you
started
there have been i think you have given
rise to so many other new
youtubers who are boldly speaking about
this
and um we need people who will tell the
truth man
we need people because people are afraid
people are just afraid
so and the only reason why i decided to
come on your channel and tell you is
because i respect what you do you know
we everyone knew thailand is
the [ __ ] he was doing everyone knew
from all these guys
that uh the bearded chap who was
speaking with his ferrari and
we know it's [ __ ] but tell me who's
speaking about it
in fact i'm even surprised you didn't
get sued for millions of dollars you
know
i think they understand that they won't
get millions of dollars out of me
i don't have millio i mean one of the
things that kind of protects me in a way
is that i'm not a valuable target to sue
and on top of that i've got a lot of
liability insurance i pay a lot of money
for a lot of the a lot of the money
that's made
from the the fake guru ads gets put
right back into covering
coffeezilla in case i get sued um that's
what that's where a lot of that goes
well hey thank you so much for coming on
loy i appreciate you shining a light on
all these issues
and uh yeah lloyd's channel will be
linked below
thanks for coming guys i hope you
enjoyed this discussion yeah see ya
all right you take care
[Music]
[Music]
never should have trusted
[Music]
comes along